is it going to get crazy by the end of
loki and
is the future just going to get
absolutely insane
uh i i think that
yes yeah yeah but but hopefully in a way
that always
is michael how's it going how's it going
man
i'm doing great because i absolutely
loved loki and i'm talking to the writer
right now yeah seriously oh it was such
a good show
uh i i truly enjoy it look he's one of
the best characters out there
and uh congrats to you on this congrats
also all the success you've had lately
uh star wars rick and morty you've been
on in the past
dr strange multiverse of madness and
thanks for being an inspiration to me
as a younger guy myself trying to be in
the industry uh look up to what you're
doing
so loki is he has to be one of the most
fun characters
to write a story for he's pure chaos
and you kind of have happen from scratch
because the loki that we saw die
was a very different locate than we have
now who hasn't been through all those
events
so what was your goal with him bigger
bolder weirder crazier what what vision
did you have for loki when you first
came on board
i think that our the the most important
thing to me
because there had been a version of loki
that we've watched
over 10 years in movies uh was
all right how do we make sure we're
doing something new with this character
um i didn't want to just tell the same
story of the guy who'd sort of
arced out through thor the dark world
ragnarok
and then infinity war so
we we wanted to figure out okay how are
we gonna
you know break new ground with this
character
yeah absolutely because it's kind of
like you know like you said yeah the
story arc it
it came to an end and it's so great to
see
a different story arc because he's such
a cool character
so you also like i mentioned before
wrote multiverse of madness which is you
know it seems like loki's causing some
trouble for the future uh multiverse as
we'll call it right
um was this a concern for you going in
or did you intentionally
put any consequences that doctor strange
might have to deal with later
well i think loki throughout the history
of the mcu is as always
uh everything he does causes
problems for people you know he was the
reason the avengers sort of came
together in the first place
um so it was always our hope
and intention with this show for it to
have a big impact on the mcu
moving forward so uh what that impact
is we'll we'll see well it looks like
it's going to have a pretty big impact
and i'm definitely really excited to see
where that's going uh you know in this
you write about
you know time travel uh different
timelines and then you're gonna write
about
the multiverse and doctor strange you
know in a way you're a pretty powerful
character right now
in the mcu these are these are huge
factors so is it going to get
crazy by the end of loki and is the
future just going to get absolutely
insane
uh i i think that
yes yeah yeah but but hopefully in a way
that always
is is driven by character
and and by emotional and investment in
the same way that the infinity saga was
you know it's you can throw as many
big crazy sci-fi concepts at something
as you want
but if the characters aren't cool and if
the emotional stories aren't resonant
you're not going to care what's what's
happening so i think
it's our challenge is as the folks the
writers the filmmakers and everybody
helping shape
this next uh phase of the mcu
you know how how do we keep expanding
the world outward
but but keep the emotion intimate
uh because because i do believe that's
ultimately
what what the fans love and and what
keeps people so invested
oh absolutely one of my favorite parts
was watching loki
just be vulnerable and raw
you know in the first episode i know
spoilers but uh that was great and i
you know we're gonna see more of that
with with more characters is this going
to be
a type of vulnerability from loki that
we've we've never seen before
i sure hope so i i think that's i think
that's what's for sale with the tv show
that that's the cool thing about
doing uh a television series about
a marvel blockbuster super villain
is is you can have longer
scenes of dialogue and quieter
um character moments than maybe you
could
in a in a big feature and and so
um i'm excited about that and that that
was always one of our big hopes with the
series
well it's definitely a lot more intimate
obviously because it's just focused on
him and i truly did enjoy
getting to know a different side of him
you've stated in previous interviews
that
you know with this series each episode
can be its own very distinct story
so you talked about each episode having
you know well
that episode that was that episode uh
which one
is your favorite and can you share a
little bit why
uh without too much but that'll give it
to you
without getting killed uh i
i mean the truth is really
the way we would move on from an episode
in the writers room
is i would say holy [ __ ] that's the best
episode ever
i love that okay
screw that episode now on to the next
one
this one's got to be the best one ever
so they're they're all
uh they're all my children i love them
all uh
and and and really i i hope they all
stan stand alone and
and also come together as hopefully one
big cool
thing well i certainly thought so i
certainly thought the
first two were very distinct episodes
and again
amazing job i truly loved it and this is
just a great character and i love
the way that you're going with them
can't wait to watch rest any
final thought that you'd like people to
leave with after watching loki
um wow
there's so much right that's such a big
question i'm sorry yeah
yeah uh
i i think that you know all of the
all the big thoughts that that i have i
poured into the show i have i have no
big thoughts left
it's all just well i'm super glad that
you put all those into the show it's
amazing so far michael thank you so much
for your time
thank you so much for loki yeah thanks
man have a good day thanks michael
you too